Johnny Depp is setting sail for the  fifth time as Captain Jack Sparrow and  this time out well there are two new  hotties making waves  this film is exciting there's something  huge happening every day so it has an  energy and a force behind it but I've  never really experienced before seen the  craftsmanship in the detail it's very  easy to lose yourself and to feel like  you are in another world going to swim  for it  it's gone far enough no it has off  twenty-five-year-old Kaya Scodelario and  27 year old britain Thwaites shot the  film Ajani on Australia's Gold Coast  Jack I'm so sorry were you still talking  you may remember the Aussie actor from  Maleficent with Angelina Jolie kaya  starred in The Maze Runner movies and  together they take on Javier Bardem new  villain creepy captain Salazar there are  new characters are gonna bring a new  flavor and a different dimension to one  of the most powerful franchises of all  time and men tell no tales  [Music]